[Musique]
non
bonjour et bienvenue dansions sortait la
nouvelle émission de tv 78 aujourd'hui
nous sommes dans la salle du jeu de
paume à versailles
nous sommes avec jacques éric piette
commissaire de l'exposition bonjour
bonjour merci nous recevoir plaisir de
vous recevoir
alors jusqu'au 31 décembre et s'il ya
une exposition sur le château de
versailles dans la bande dessinée
comment vous est venue cette idée le
château de versailles entretient des
liens étroits avec la bande dessinée
depuis plusieurs années le château cos
édite plusieurs albums de bandes
dessinées et globalement nous savions
que la bande dessinée
le château de versailles était très
présent au sein de la bande dessinée et
il nous apparaissait donc naturel de
proposer une exposition sur ce sujet qui
prenait toute sa place en 2020 année
nationale consacrée par le ministère de
la culture à la bande dessinée
justement c'est cette année c'est
considéré comme le neuvième art qu'est
ce qui a fait le basculement le
changement pourquoi cette année par le
basculement de du statut de la bande
dessinée à 9e art est finalement assez
progressif au cours du 20e siècle
c'est un lent mouvement de
reconnaissance et de légitimation et qui
effectivement a pris toute sa place dans
les dernières décennies entre l'essor du
festival d'angoulême d'une part
l'arrivée de la bande dessinée dans des
ventes aux enchères qui lui sont
consacrés la création de galeries et
puis la multiplication des expositions
dans les lieux culturels musées
bibliothèques qui sont consacrés à la
bande dessinée donc finalement
effectivement en 2020 cette année
nationale qui avait pour vocation à
mettre un coup de projecteur sur le 9e
art dans quelle mesure le château de
versailles est une source d'inspiration
pour les auteurs de bd
il nous est apparu que le château de
versailles avait une dimension tout à
fait ikonik pour les auteurs de bandes
dessinées qui leur permet
en un dessin finalement de convoquer un
tout un imaginaire pour les lecteurs un
imaginaire l'issue de films de séries de
lecture de romans l'issue de la lecture
d'autres bandes dessinées aussi et c'est
sans doute ce qui justifie y de la place
du château la place toute particulière
du château au sein de la bande dessinée
la manière dont nous avons travaillé a
été de chercher à faire une recension de
l'ensemble des albums ou série qui
s'intéressait au château on a trouvé
plus d'une centaine d'albums ou série
donc finalement plusieurs centaines
d'albums mis bout-à-bout et au sein de
ses albums nous avons ensuite cherché à
identifier les planches qui nous
intéressait le plus particulièrement
puis entrer en contact avec les
propriétaires de ces planches qui était
souvent les auteurs et puis ensuite au
regard des planches que nous avions pu
trouver nous avons cherché à constituer
l'exposition l'organisation
d'expositions sur ce que ces planches
nous disait du château on arrive donc à
exposer aujourd'hui une centaine de
planches comme vous le disiez d'une
quarantaine d'auteurs différents
permettant de donner un aperçu de toute
la diversité des regards portés sur le
château de versailles dans la bande
dessinée et sur ses planches on voit
quoi alors c'est le château les jardins
les intérieurs cd et revue historique
c'est on s'est intéressé à la fois aux
représentations du château et de ses
lieux aussi bien les bâtiments que les
espaces intérieurs ou les espaces
extérieurs comme les jardins des lieux
parfois disparu on aperçoit la ménagerie
on aperçoit des appartements intérieur
qui ont subi depuis des années
ajm ans et puis on a considéré que
faisait pas pleinement parti de
versailles et de son image les grandes
figures historiques et les grands
événements qui étaient associés par
exemple une représentation de louis xiv
en dehors de versailles ou une
représentation en lien avec la
révolution française ont nécessairement
des liens avec versailles donc c'est
cette diversité finalement qui a conduit
notre travail de recherche
on dit souvent que versailles rayonne
dans le monde et si ce sont des offres
qui sont françaises international belge
alors nous et faisons essentiellement
des oeuvres effectivement édité en
france pour la plupart d'auteur français
belges comme vous le disiez mais aussi
de dessinateur italien
et puis on fait simplement un clin
d'oeil je dirais l'univers du manga à
travers une vitrine dans laquelle nous
présentons des éditions originales en
japonais est effectivement le château de
versailles a eu aussi une certaine
renommée un certain succès dans la bande
dessinée asiatique et particulièrement
au japon et donc danser dans ses oeuvres
japonaises
on met quoi en avance et le château
l'histoire de france dans le manga on
s'est plus particulièrement intéressé
finalement à la période de la révolution
française et la figure de marie
antoinette qui apparaît comme une icône
un peu romantique en réalité un symbole
de la france sans doute en extrême
orient est donc là on est dans la salle
du jeu de paume
ce lieu j'imagine qu'il n'a pas été
choisie au hasard oui tout à fait il
nous semble intéressant de pouvoir
présenter la bande dessinée dans un lieu
historique
un lieu qui est a fortiori entretient un
rapport étroit avec les arts du dessin
vous avez derrière nous
le
une peinture reprenant le fameux dessin
de david sur le serment du jeu de paume
est donc cette exposition est à voir
jusqu'au 31 décembre
jusqu'au 31 décembre tous les jours en
accès gratuit ok très bien il bien merci
beaucoup c'est moi qui vous remercie
merci d'avoir suivi cette émission et on
vous convient tôt pour des nouvelles
idées de sorties dans les yvelines
[Musique]
non